the mandalorian second season has really
put dinjarin to the ringer
in addition to fighting a crate dragon
and one horde after the next of enemies
he's also had his entire belief system
questioned upon learning he's actually a
child
of the watch an extremist sect of
mandalorians who aim to re-establish the
ancient order of their kind
part of their creed involves never
removing one's helmet which
din has stuck to there have only been
two times so far in the series when
we've seen dyn's face
the first comes when he suffers injuries
and has to remove his helmet for
treatment
only revealing his face to an unliving
droid voiced by taika waititi
the second time occurs in chapter 15
when dinosaur gained access to sensitive
materials
from the empire by showing his face it
appears as though din is questioning his
belief system more and more in recent
episodes
and even though he's still hesitant to
remove his helmet he's willing to do so
if it means saving grogo
rumors have been circling that the
reason for these increasingly common
face reveals lies in pedro pascal
wanting more face time on the star wars
series
some rumors even extend to the point of
saying pascal would leave the show if he
continued being hidden behind all that
best guy all the time
in a recent television appearance he
laid those rumors to rest
and assured fans that he's perfectly
happy doing what's best for the show
audiences will be able to see pedro
pascal's face front and center
in the upcoming superhero sequel wonder
woman 1984
as the villain nurse maxwell lord as
such he's been doing a whole lot of
media appearances
in promotion of the film when he called
in virtually on the one show
the topic shifted to his work on the
mandalorian he was asked point blank
about the rumors that purport he wants
his helmet off more often
pascal was quick to deny them after
saying the rumors aren't true he went on
to state
it's a really wonderful way of telling
the story it's always been a very clear
creed for the character
and the collaborative process of the
whole thing we've all been on the same
page with this
so what i want is for them to make the
best show possible however they get that
done
it sounds as though pascal understands
why the creative forces behind the show
won dinjarin's helmet on and he's
totally cool with going along for the
ride
and performing however is best for the
character it's clear how deeply the
character believes in the mandalorian
creed
and when he takes off his helmet in
chapter 15 it is obvious how
uncomfortable
it makes him perhaps he'll open up more
in the future when more circumstances
arise that require him to reveal himself
by all accounts pascal will be
portraying dinjarin for quite some time
to come
disney has announced the mandalorian
will return for season 3
sometime in december 2021 via collider
during the recent disney investor day
event the company announced a slew of
star wars projects
including two that will take place at
the same time as the events of the
mandalorian
an ahsoka tano series and rangers of the
new republic
all of these shows will cross over in a
big climactic event
so is within the realm of possibility
that din might show up on these other
series as well
with plenty more adventures coming down
the pipeline it's likely we're going to
see denjarin continue to wrestle with
what he has learned from boca tan crees
and the nighthouse other mandalorians
are out there
and they don't necessarily believe in
the same things he does instead they're
out there trying to regain their
homeworld
and the day may come when the night owls
require his assistance for a certain job
while den still not completely
comfortable taking his helmet off he may
get more comfortable with the idea
if he gets the chance to spend more time
with the different sect of mandalorians
who want to strict with the rules as he
is you can see pedro pascal next when
the final episode of the mandalorian
season 2
airs on disney plus on december 18 2020
a week later on december 25th you can
see him again over on hbo max and in
theaters where they're open
in wonder woman 1984. check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
tv shows and
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one